before we begin since this is a BBC
owned property I feel the need to point
out that the news armor the BBC has a
continuing issue with transphobic
leanings in its news coverage you can
find in a pinned comment below various
videos from both myself and other
YouTubers covering this issue and while
I understand that the Doctor Who
creative team is not responsible for
this I will continue to point this out
for as long as it remains a consistent
issue thank you
[Music]
well they can't all be winners
thank you
[Music]
so recently I did a revisit to my list
of the top 10 best one time Doctor Who
villains but
can't really have a best list without a
worse list can ya
well you can except the worst lists tend
to be more popular anyway so
here we are plus I thought it'd be fun
to revisit this idea because it's been a
while
now uh definition of one time I do
consider two partners to be only one
story so any uh villain who appeared in
a two-part story does qualify
um yeah I think that's about all I have
to say this is going to be pretty
straightforward it is going to be
restricted to New Era Doctor Who because
as I mentioned when I Revisited my best
one-time uh villains the classic era
featured
so many one-timers that it it just
encapsulates more than I am able to wrap
my brain around especially considering
I'm still working my way through classic
I've got holes in my knowledge there but
in any case let us take a look at the
worst villains that the show smartly
never brought back
number 10.
the absorbable off look I'm getting the
obvious one out of the way real early on
this the absorbable office honestly
largely a failure of execution the core
idea and especially how he functions
within the narrative isn't a bad notion
the whole idea of the way that he kind
of embodies toxic fandom and he wants to
just bring every other fan of the doctor
in the Linda group to just be just like
him to be part of him to absorb their
enthusiasm for the doctor into his
nastiness and his hatred and his
prescribed correct sort of way of
viewing things it works metaphorically
as a practical matter even before we see
the suit the characterization of the
performance is so Arch that it really
kind of kills the potential for this
character as a villain and even as a
symbolic and metaphorical thing kind of
as I said like I do still think you have
to take that at least a little seriously
because he can't take this guy seriously
that's before you even see what he ends
up looking like and once you do see what
he ends up looking like
yeah there's a reason this guy's been a
punch line for a long time but again
obviously I don't think he's the worst
there was still some potential there and
there's some little bits here and there
like there's something it just didn't
quite pull together like at all
number nine
the future kind so this is going to be
the first of several entries that will
fall into the category of villain and or
monster that doesn't need to be there at
all
one thing that is really frustrating
about New Era Doctor Who arguably
classic Doctor Who as well but I feel
like it's more noticeable as a problem
in modern era is the need to shoehorn in
a monster and or villain into every
story even if there's plenty to deal
with and sufficient threats without that
in this case we are dealing with the
episode Utopia we are dealing with the
End of Time entropy has one humanity is
trying to escape before the last
remnants of this rock that is even
vaguely habitable falls apart and
they're trying to get somewhere else so
that they can continue to exist that is
threat enough if you need to like really
you know kick a boot up the butt of the
plot have it that the planet itself is
about to fall apart crumble whatever
these humans with these just weird teeth
and sort of oddly devolved Minds why and
the name like future kind and said like
this is what we will become what why
like I guess theoretically is trying to
see the idea of what will eventually
happen later with the taco Fame but the
tacophan are a very different kind of
monstrosity from these things so that
doesn't even really track
they're just there
because the story needed a threat except
it didn't it had one it just threw these
things in anyways yeah
number eight
the Reapers
this is one some people some people are
going to come at me for this one because
I know I know there is a contingent of
fans out there who really think these
things should come back I could not be
happier that they never have I think
they're a terrible idea and they also
suffer from what I just mentioned with
the future time which is story doesn't
need them you created a paradox just
have time falling apart just have
reality and causality unravel that is
the threat you don't need monsters to do
that you don't need to rip off freaking
Stephen King's The Langoliers which
isn't even that good a Stephen King's
Story in order to do it
these things add nothing there is
nothing that they bring that would not
have already been inherent to the idea
of just reality collapsing which is in
here a little but I think would have
been far more effective than having
these things show up and not to mention
the fact that the whole idea that gets
planted with they sort of come into like
clean up and eat away at anomalies and
paradoxes or whatever by that logic we
should have seen them a hell of a lot
since then and there's a reason we
haven't because they don't work
they're not interesting they're Bland
they're boring conceptually in terms of
when they show up like maybe you could
do something with that but the execution
of what they are how they operate they
are generic as hell and they aren't
necessary to this story I think Father's
Day is overrated in general but my
biggest problem with that story is these
things
number seven
the morax
this is from the witch Hunters and yet
again falls under the category of uh we
didn't need these
there is a perfectly serviceable villain
there is a perfectly serviceable human
villain this legitimately could have
really worked as a pure historical
really delved into the way that
communities would rip themselves apart
out of fear or misguided Notions of like
righteousness there was a lot to work
with there it was even being worked with
fairly well and then suddenly this Mud
Monster takes over the rather
interesting human villain and does a
massive Exposition dump to be able to
explain why the hell we're now doing
this it disengages from everything these
things do not thematically or
logistically tie into anything that have
been going on with the tensions between
the the people in this town with King
James with any of it they just they're
just there they're just there and this
is what the climax is going to be why
why this doesn't tie off any of the
conflicts we've actually been dealing
with anything even vaguely approaching a
satisfactory way get rid of these things
number six
Leandro
or who I keep thinking of is Lionel I
can't help it so this one is from uh the
woman who lived and I will say that
unlike the last few there is a reason
for him to be here because if you don't
present some kind of villain then this
episode isn't going to be much more than
just a travel log of ishoulder's life
and that wow the most interesting part
of the story isn't really gonna carry it
completely on its own you need a
conflict to sort of bring it all
together
but it's why why this guy why does he
look like a lion why why is he doing
anything why does his shoulder fall in
with him she seems honestly too
intelligent for this to be pulled in by
this guy who has some weird generic plan
that I don't remember the only thing I
remember about him is that he looks like
a live-action Thundercat that's
literally the only thing I can ever
remember about this guy
and this is a story that actually did
kind of need a villain but like one that
works that does something that is
memorable for anything other than
looking like you stepped out of a Furry
Convention
like I why why
nothing against furries by the way but
like why here why now what are we doing
number five
Dr Lazarus
oh boy okay so there's a couple of
things going on with this one first of
all let's deal with the elephant in the
room
horrendous CGI this thing looks real bad
and not just on the final render but
like conceptually what is this if the
core idea is that this thing is somehow
hidden within our DNA and like a
direction the human race could have gone
you pushed it too far I don't buy it as
a premise I don't buy that that's what
this is and if this was ever going to be
interesting it needed to retain some
degree of his intelligence but instead
it just he turns into a monster and
Roars and tries to kill people or does
kill people in a few cases and that's it
there's no hint of the intellect why why
is his brain friggin Vanishing when he
turns into this thing
and what is motivating this thing to
behave the way that it does
no answer it's just this is It's the
monster he turns into because we need a
we need a monster look if you wanted to
go Jekyll and Hyde just do Jekyll and
hide and have him be you know a little
bit you know more dangerous more bugged
up but have you know deal with the
mental deterioration when this
transformation happens don't just take
it as assumed don't just throw this
thing at us this pile of pixels that
didn't even look good at the time and it
really doesn't look good now
this character is
uninteresting
and weird in a way that is kind of
boring like if you were to tell me that
a guy makes himself younger but then
turns into his mom into a monster I
wouldn't imagine that he looked like
this but once you show me that I'd be
like oh okay so we're just we're not
trying are we or maybe we're trying so
hard that you might as well have not
tried maybe that's what it is because
this thing is over designed to hell
number four
the shock Cree from the power of three
this might honestly be the single most
forgettable villain in all of Doctor Who
and I feel pretty confident in saying
that you want to know why it wasn't
until I sat down to edit this footage
that I realized I didn't even record the
entry for this guy
like what else is there for me to say he
basically just sits there does nothing
he just gets talked about and I know the
word is that the actor was the problem
here except honestly I've tried
corroborating that and it's not as
supported as you might think it is it's
still possible but however this happened
again I literally forgot to talk about
him when I sat down to shoot this that's
why you haven't been seeing my face for
this entire entry
I think that says it all moving on
number three
the the burnt creatures crispy I don't I
don't call these things they're from
Journey to the Center of the TARDIS
whatever these things were
so
kind of springboarding off of what I
said about Dr Lazarus where I had this
whole thing of like okay so he turns
into this but why does he just act like
a monster you know why doesn't he retain
any of his intellect and if he's not
going to then what was the point of
having him be like a scientist we didn't
get to know him or anything but like
here it's that but worse
because what we eventually find out
these things are are melted together
versions of the characters in the story
including the doctor
and for some reason there's you know
they kind of burn and melt and whatever
and just don't look
they just it's just okay it's a burnt
it's a burnt body okay and it's
shuffling towards you so it's got kind
of a weird Zombie thing but it's also
like
it's very generic like why are they
acting like that why are they behaving
like that why are they a threat
like if you're gonna have them as
something that was like seen in the
distance and be like oh what was that
and then you find out what it was and I
was like oh but the fact that it's like
that these things are like chasing them
why why are they doing that it's like
this thing in Doctor Who where once
characters who are not monsters and are
not villains suddenly something happens
to them that they physically take on the
form of a month they they'll just act
like a monster now it's as if they were
never anything but a monster to go by
their behavior
yeah no just just know
number two
The Wire
some folks might have been expecting
this one at the top we'll get to what
the number one was in a second but uh
yeah this is from my single most hated
episode of Doctor Who now the reason why
I deeply loathedience Lantern is not
because of the wire specifically but the
wire doesn't help
and the wire is such squandered
potential
because they cast really smartly she
sells so well that sort of bright warm
welcoming method of talking are you
sitting comfortably then we'll begin
it's perfect
but that sense of unease that you get
from a warm and welcoming voice talking
to you and talking about killing people
and and enacting this plan to do massive
damage that contrast that makes it fun
is completely lost when in the entire
second half of the episode is just her
going
hungry over and over and over and over
again
really really irritating and whatever
potential there was in the idea of this
digital monster which had a lot of
potential and they had a really good
actress cast in it and then just threw
it away
on cheap lightning effects and Phoebe ah
and number one
the skovox Blitzer
I had forgotten about this thing until I
did my re-watch a little while back and
when I got to this episode this time
it's stuck in my head
this supposed
perfect killing machine
that they built something that looks
okay when it's not moving but it clearly
didn't look great when it was moving and
they didn't know how to puppet it very
well and so it's cut together really
choppily so you've got your seam showing
with that that's a technical limitation
that doesn't help but then just
it announces literally
everything it is doing
[Music]
it
whatever it's doing it is announcing it
loudly publicly broadcasting it and we
have this whole thing of how dangerous
this thing is I was one of the most
dangerous killing machines how
how it was clearly designed by idiots
why would anything like this is
this is a general recurrent thing not
just with a doctor who but with a lot of
Science Fiction stuff where this stuff
like says out loud I mean to pull Doctor
Who itself when you've got things like
Voyage of the Damned and you've got the
um whatever they call them the the the
the things that look like angels and
it's going kill kill kill
like that's stupid too but at least that
thing's malfunctioning so you can kind
of come up with an excuse here this
thing's working as designed it's
designed to be like that I can't take it
seriously as a threat it never actually
seems like it's going to be dangerous
and it's so irritating having around
just listening to it announce everything
it's doing it it takes the top spot for
not just being
a worthless addition to the story that
it's in not that the caretaker is an
amazing story but it's not only fails to
add anything
it's just stupid
as a villain this does not work this
this is this is what I'd expect from a
robotic villain in an early 1990s
Saturday morning cartoon and I know
Doctor Who can be cartoonish sometimes
not to this degree
release is not supposed to be
ah
oh well
what are your most disliked despised or
derided ooh 3DS
gotcha
I have a habit of doing that trying to
snap with these things on anyways
whatever ones you think should have made
the list or your thoughts of the ones
that are on the because I know like I I
ask people on Twitter I know there are
lots that people do not like that I did
not put on this list not necessarily
because I think they're good but because
I thought these were worse but whatever
your thoughts are drop something down in
the comments let's talk about it patreon
pays the bills enables me to do this as
my living gets you early access to
videos like this as well as other perks
but uh don't worry too much about it
like share subscribe help me out as well
but what I really want you to do
is remember
that you are beautiful
you are valid
you are loved
you are the council I'm just running the
meetings and until next time this
Council
is adjourned
[Music]
my thanks to all my patrons but in
particular I want to thank Robin Moore
Zubin lotfulla Sarvis to rock the thing
that goes doing in the anime Ruth Oliver
B solitary pictures
ulurik Bogdan Melinda Walters imudelki
Leo the Boyd Auntie Kate 808 Becky
Sparks fernandby likes the poodle Robin
Powell Tracy scrabot angry Casper Tim
price Adam RDL Taylor goddess Elita
Elida not sure ah David Hall Shayla
Gourley Rosalind Bennett
you want to hear me mess up your name
too it's in the patreon perks
I gotta work on that
[Music]
foreign